bonjour je m'appelle Julien Maresque
j'ai 24 ans je viens de Saint-Benoît et
j'ai un enfant donc dans le cadre de mon
BTS j'aime je souhaiterais trouver un
contrat d'alternance en tant
qu'assistant manager dans toute
entreprise que ce soit assistante de
direction assistant ressources humaines
assistant manager tout ce qui est
assistant plutôt sur Saint-Benoît ou
Saint-Denis car je n'ai pas le permis du
coup pour le transport c'est un peu
compliqué j'ai décroché le baccalauréat
littéraire et j'ai suivi une formation
en langue en espagnol en anglais et
portugais
et maintenant j'aimerais tenter autre
chose pour pouvoir découvrir une autre
face de ma personnalité et surtout
décrocher de l'expérience
professionnelle ce qui viendra compléter
mon cursus scolaire d'assistante manager
donc voilà si n'hésitez pas à me
contacter je suis disponible tous les
jours 24 heures sur 24 7 jours sur 7 il
y a pas de souci